well joining us are the Royal
correspondent for Vanity Fair Katie
Nichol and the sun's Royal editor Matt
Wilkinson who I think has been whizzing
through an entire copy of the book is
that right Matt
this is Spanish version The Enormous
pleasure of reading the book oh well you
don't sound as if it was yeah
tell us what you found no it was it's a
it's an incredible book and I think
you've gone through some of the main
headlines here today but I don't think
I've ever read a royal book of so many
Revelations and the most important thing
here is there's so many Revelations from
a member of the royal family and I think
that's what the issue is here there are
as Katie will tell you there are many
many raw books she's written some
herself but there are many many raw
books but the problem here is that a
beloved member of the family like a
treasured brother of William a son of
Charles he's the one that is actually
airing all this dirty linen this is the
problem that the royal family are facing
because there's all sorts of stories all
sorts of Revelations that come out about
the royal family the problem is is that
the senior member of the royal family is
actually making these accusations but
also revealing the private lives the
private conversations situations with
Kate and William that would normally be
behind closed doors or normally the
journalists would not be allowed to
report on or if we tried to report on
them we would told it was too private
but I'd say we have a you know a brother
of William and the son of childhood is
actually making these things public and
I think that's the most aggravating
element of this I mean there is so much
to say we've already learned so many
extraordinary things from this book what
is a single story if you like that jumps
out at you the most that left you with a
jaw dropping I can certainly tell you
what mine my take on it is but I'd love
to hear from you
well the ones I think it's about Harry's
life it's about his drug taking and the
losing the losing his virginity I mean
these are things that members of the
royal family don't normally talk about
you know he's talking about talking
about his time in the Army Afghanistan
where he was saying that he killed 25 uh
people of the Taliban but it's this
opening up of his personal life about
the sword to tell about him losing his
virginity behind a pub and about his
cocaine taking and his he's opening up
elements about where he was
hallucinating and talking to a bin I
mean these are really deeply deeply
personal stories from from you know from
from Prince Harry just unbelievable Matt
I mean Katie Where Do We Begin how how
shocked are you by these Revelations I
think after the um after the sort of the
Netflix documentary you sort of thought
what else is to come out I think I said
that didn't I now I'm feeling really
silly because I I didn't think that he
was going to go anywhere near where he's
gone I mean I I completely agree with
what Matt's just said I mean I I've done
this job now for nearly 17 years I'm you
know he's not the first member of the
royal family to write a book but he is
certainly the only member of the royal
family to have written a book this
explosive I mean those Bombshells just
come thick and fast and I think
we've almost become oversaturated by
Harry and Megan and this narrative
there's just so much of it but actually
if you try and just forget the docu
series if you try and put that Oprah
interview to aside you just come into
this book
the idea that a senior member with royal
family would write a book like this I
mean I would say is Unthinkable you you
really have to stop and think I cannot
believe what I really particularly by
the way as well the account of him
losing his virginity unless that's a
dodgy Spanish translation I am
astonished it is jaw-dropping there's
language it is in there that I'm not
even sure
we're a family program I mean look you
and I sort of generally have a pretty
dim view of talking about Harry and
Megan the whole time but we both agreed
that this show can only be all about
Harry and Megan for tonight only because
it is utterly Sensational isn't it it
really is I mean the Oprah interview was
was jaw-dropping but that did focus on a
sort of a a short a short period this
spans his entire life and I think for me
having written biographies about him and
spanning those early years it is you
raised the question Katie about
what's believable and is this all
believable I mean there are serious
questions about what Megan said in the
Winfrey interview so
how much of this really is believable or
is some of it just exaggerated unlike
Matt I've not had the privilege yet of
reading the entire book um I mean one
inconsistency that jumped out
immediately was Harry saying that after
he'd been allegedly shoved to the ground
and had this physical fisticuffs with
his brother his first call was to his
therapist well my first call would
probably be to my other half but the
fact is the other half had said she
wasn't allowed to see a therapist
because it wasn't a good look for the
royal family it didn't it wasn't but but
actually how does that Harry has a
therapist on speed dial yeah and so I'm
sure we we will pick over the narrative
and there will be discrepancies and I
suppose we ought to point out the
obvious which is this is one person's
side of the story there are always two
sides to the story but unfortunately
we're not going to get to hear the other
side of Charles's narrative or Williams
because they're not going to go yeah
let's just come back to Matt because he
has read the whole thing
um I have two quick questions on that we
haven't heard much so far about what
Harry has to say about the queen and any
conversations that he had with her and
so I wonder if you could tell us a bit
about that and also can you just
elaborate on that bin story you told us
about just now you referred to Harry
hallucinating talking to a bin I think
we need to know more of that
yeah we'll be hopefully putting more in
the paper very shortly but there is a
there is there are scenes or there are
scenes that he has written about about
taking some drugs while at Eaton and it
goes into quite a lot of detail about
hallucinating
um with some friends
um wrong spliffs and talking to a to a a
bin that talks back to him and it's like
opening up a kind of scene as a teenager
addressing the kind of
I mean he
he I mean he's supposed to be fair to
her he has always been publicly he's
always been very respectful about the
queen and it is he's very respectful
about the queen in the book
um you'll be seeing later that he he
does talk about his trip to say goodbye
to the queen as in he he talks about his
trip we went to Balmoral there's an
epilogue that I think you might be aware
of that he'd written the book uh over
the summer he'd been signed it had gone
but he's written an epilogue
um talking about when he learned that
the queen had died the conversations
that you had with with the King and
flying up without Megan and then saying
a personal goodbye to his grandmother
and that's quite touching
um I mean again it's a very personal
story that he's revealing a lot of
detail about the moments that he had
with the queen with the queen about
moral but you're right he's
he's not gone in much detail on
Revelations about the queen because I
don't really think that's that's
tasteful there might not be any but
there is there are scenes where he is
talking in his epilogue about about well
I can't wait to hear all the detail in
the paper tomorrow thank you very much
Matthew and um Richard I mean Where Do
We Begin what was in his mind when he
thought that it was right to reveal
these extraordinary details did he think
that in the modern world it's good to
reveal details about your drug taking
and your virginity because he's one of
of the things that struck me is where he
says in one of his televised interviews
and we've seen the clips of them
um I don't think anything can be
improved by me keeping quiet I mean just
how stupid is he I mean Katie how thick
is Prince Harry sorry to ask her well he
didn't do terribly well in his a levels
I mean we we know that we didn't go on
to University and he went into Sandhurst
um but
I I don't know there's a lot of people
will be thinking he is incredibly
deluded to to have done this I mean the
idea that he says in in one sentence
that the door is open for a potential
return I'm assuming for a Reconciliation
that he he believes in the future of the
monarchy is so incongruous with what
he's doing and the impact of his words
and what the impact of those words is
having on the monarchy it's almost like
he is just deluded and lost in his own
world we'll have to talk about what's he
trying to achieve with all of this I
think apart from earning a load of cash
well I mean clearly that he's gone for
the big bucks I mean that is
indisputable and you're not going to get
35 million dollars
worth they certainly have but I think I
think there was a genuine desire for him
to tell his own narrative to tell I mean
I I was told many years his truth his
Megan's truth but I do think he has felt
unheard for a very long time and just
just to play Devil's Advocate just
slightly here I that idea of being the
spare is something he has struggled with
for a long time I have met Harry on many
occasions he said to me before in the
past you know I just I want a normal
life I want to get on the tube I want to
go and be able to buy a coffee I want to
be able to do this he wanted everything
that he didn't have that wasn't within
his Birthright and I'm afraid he has
wanted all of the Privileges of being
Royal and none of the responsibilities
and the underlying sentiment in all of
this I do not see him take
responsibility for anything this is it I
mean he literally wants to have his cake
and eat it at all times yes including
wanting to be in the royal family and
out of the royal family making money
whilst representing the queen it wasn't
going to work he's tried to create this
third way I I don't believe it has
worked Katie you're going to stick
around thank you very much indeed for
that